une fois de plus le système américain
d'immigration est mise à rude épreuve
des milliers de migrants attendaient la
levée du titre 42 mesure anti-covites
qui permettait d'expulser immédiatement
tous migrants illégal entrant aux
États-Unis la mesure reste encore en
place résultat une nouvelle crise
humanitaire de chaque côté de la
frontière avec le Mexique en très grand
nombre des venezueliens des cubales des
nicaraguayens et des Haïtiens fuyant
leur pays pour des raisons politiques et
économiques
le président Joe Biden faute
d'approbation au Congrès d'une politique
cohérente et des moyens financiers pour
réformer le système annoncé des mesures
pour pallier aux plusieurs gens il est
temps un système déjà prévu pour le
Venezuela aux trois autres pays
to be gun Noah
il est prêt à admettre 30 000 migrants
de ces quatre pays par mois à condition
qu'il soit parrainés par un parent ou
une entreprise et qu'il réponde aux
critères de sécurité prévue qu'ils
peuvent le faire avec cette application
mobile CBP one pour leur demander
d'asile et pour montrer à la frontière
s'ils sont acceptés
de 1100 à 250 en un mois
Joe Biden va rencontrer son homologue
mexicain Andres manuel Lopes Obrador la
semaine prochaine à Mexico avec le
Premier ministre Trudeau il se rendra
d'abord dimanche à la frontière pour
constater lui-même l'ampleur de la crise
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal